if my goal was just to be famous which I
don't want then I would be all in on
Tick Tock but here's a different way of
thinking about it when I'm going to
search for the new iPhone comes out
where do I go look for that video I go
to youtube.com and I type in the YouTube
search box that is where I want to live
for those people who are searching for
that information if that answer ever
changes if it's like the new phone came
out let me go into Tick Tock and see
what people are saying about the phone
then I guess that is when I'll feel that
pressure but I think for the people who
feel the pressure to be relevant or the
pressure for the eyeballs or the fame or
something like that then you'll feel the
pressure because Tick Tock is a hundred
percent accomplishing that now the most
viewed piece of content I have ever made
in 15 years is a 12 second Tick Tock of
me unfolding the LG wing it has 35
million views if I wanted the eyeballs I
would be all over Tick Tock but I'm
trying to make valuable content for them
and so that's still YouTube
foreign